hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to let's play pace a de l'eau de
l'eau now if you guys remember I
actually played this game before back
when it was just the demo level this is
officially the full game / the full game
I'm not sure if it's a full full game
but it's definitely a lot more than
there was because I played the other one
back and I think December so here I am
visiting this again and as you can
obviously tell this is in Brazilian and
I do not speak that language or whatever
language they speak in the country of
Brazil out of Portuguese I don't know so
anyway so we're gonna start playing it
and I'm gonna have no idea what's going
on
it doesn't this should I'm imagining
that the first level will be awfully
similar to what I played before so I
should be able to get through it quickly
with limited interference from the
monster use attack la época para Pilar
use our Tecla in de cada para intead
okay I'm good use apron Chetta para
salvar a sway Progresso mmm I love that
soup okay so basically oh they didn't
fix the mouse outside of the game thing
hopefully I won't have to click on
anything
Oh No falta uma evolved ova para llegar
yoga where go I'm so sorry everybody
I am NOT meaning to be so mean what is
that
hiccup agar I found a tool belt of sorts
and a blood-stained chair pammi neat Ave
which stands for mini key I remember the
many keys I bury a note ah how do I read
the note let's see here oh I don't even
know why I'm trying I can't solve are
all right then
wherever you stay buddy hey guy hey
whatever you
hello remember me remember me good buddy
friend oh all right I got to check all
of the benches to make sure why does my
flashlight just not go into that
darkness over there that dashboard you
happened with my flashlight to supposed
to spread my light all over the world I
know there's a monster right there
because I've seen it before
I've been there I've done that I'm not
getting that not yet anyway
ha hey you hold your horses there I'm
not scared at anything especially not
any of you solve our progress oh but I
what does that mean what that okay
apparently not okay that's not gonna
happen
okay this is where you put in too many
keys to try to get um the major key that
the last key is in there so I just gotta
go through here go to the right here be
on my weary weary weary weary now Dixie
let a bear us new Bulava okay there's oh
yeah I forgot that's where uh I won't
tell you guys for those of you who have
not played the game I'll act like I
haven't played this before Oh Oh what
could go wrong I laugh in the face of
danger
hey oh look a mini key hmm
I love the mini keys okay
is that what I normally act like when I
don't know what I'm gonna ha ha ha oh
look there's a purple thing on the
ground well I'll just go over walk ooh
good it what could go wrong chav a I'm
in a strata wait I thought something
happened when I picked that up maybe I'm
me hey where did the monsters show up
I'll know for oxido ankle travail de
porta see guada attend show aha
some of these rooms didn't open before
so they're definitely some new things
going on here all right that's three of
four mini keys hello what was what did I
just get I don't know but I hear a
monster us leaking around okay I've got
three mini keys a bomb beena which looks
like a candy in a kayak solid F
bosphoros phosphorous match all right
that's all there isn't here right what's
up oh I got locked in I didn't know that
boom what the hell
that candy exploded why must have been
some candy okay I need weight huh
there's no panel on that I need to get
the panel for that and there's only one
more mini key that I need to get which
must be in this area over here Hey look
it's a screwdriver hello
don't f with me lightning I'm far too
amazing to be bothered by the likes of
you okay so that means wait what's going
on here a minute
what do I do is a screwdriver for I
remember I use it for something but I I
can't remember what port at transia / -
can I use it on anything no no I need to
go to the admin Starkel administer
aikido administer ro let me check the
park benches one more time just in case
as anything on them I do not think so
saya doc coot when did the monster show
up last time I have no idea maybe he's
not gonna show up this time
or maybe he's right around the corner
maybe he's right behind you maybe he's
right behind me it wasn't okay I need to
find the administrative office okay ah
administrate tolchin administer Otterton
it's really annoying
cuz my mouse is like literally going all
over the place outside of the game
window here but oh yeah administer uh
administer chi chi down here right here
okay
ah I remember that that happened before
god damn it [ __ ] you okay there's a
fourth mini Kyary 4 2 1 3 4 2 1 3 hey
remember don't think I don't remember I
remember
all right 4 2 1 3 I got all the mini
keys so let's go open the mini key thing
it dark is really dark
alright terrif
well where was the mini key dispenser it
was summer 4 2 1 3 4 2 1 3 4 2 1 3 oh
yeah I need to turn on the power was
that it was it 4 3 1 2 4 2 1 oh it was
right there ok good
ok 4 2 1 3 oh yeah um no I'm so great
woah oh I have all that wasn't a mini
key ah wait no yeah I picked up a mini
key I did I thought I did oh no that's
cuz I just used the oh I'm an idiot
okay everyone ignore me cuz I'm so
stupid I can't even figure this all out
come on 4 2 1 3
yeah go team go go team markiplier
you're the best at horror games and
whatnot 4 1 3 just gotta get it family
get a good I got turn these key elavil
Louisville ok ok 4 2 1 3
yeah yeah yeah gotta get a good shift
oh oh yeah it's gonna blow I forgot it's
gonna like it
what are you so you're looking out there
what are you looking at there were you
looking what were you looking at huh
okay um I gotta get I gotta go over here
hmm
stop it and I gotta get the yeah and
then the the ultraviolet lights and then
I gotta go the other bathroom this is
Assessor scizor scizor scizor scizor
scizor zazas zazas ah ah 2 3 3 1 2 3 3 2
1 2 3 3 1 2 3 3 1 let's go let's go
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go 2 3 3 1 do 3 $31 there 1 2 3 3
1 enter go in yeah what's in here what's
in here one less key key to the outside
ha ha did it get a get a get a get
eating what are you talking about
what does this go do what are you go do
Oban euros ah oh come on what's the
point what's the point of that what's
the point of that what's the point of
that what's the point of that what did I
get
what did they get no I gotta solve it
the what ah top hat Tom bet
shut up shut up a hole I gotta find out
there it is Minnie I got the last mini
key that was it that was it
I forgot that I don't needed to get
those boots to school lose to school
screw everything we're on a time crunch
here buddy
you back up you stupid echoing whoo you
sober was that salvano I haven't found
all the pages nuts I just froze there
for a second open open open you dick
ciao bye master master key I laugh in
the face of danger
ha ha ha please thank you okay we're
running this way through a cave as is
smart wait where's the cave there's
nothing here
wait did nothing here okay
yeah
Tisa you say up rancette up Oh ooh
steadily Kazuki tada lebara will be
charlie they beep the bibliotheca
biblioteca means library in Spanish okay
so now we're officially at a place I've
never been before so that that's real
good oh that's just a projector okay
in surah on CD not project or so insert
a CD into the projector pegar I don't
know I'm betting there were more pages
in the last level than I need to define
to solve some sort of puzzle I'm not
sure what you still a check probably
easy to miss something in these books
don't know how I got here oh there okay
I see ha ha ha
star da Syeda hey I love buncha histoy
in got to win these pantalones suck it
Wade Wade hates it when I sing that song
wrong or correctly I sing it correctly
everyone else does it wrong okay so I
got some sort of one is that black
lights or fuse I think fuse never seen a
purple fuse before but whatever
color-coded for your convenience
color-coded for your pleasure
alright another paper so I can solve
this stupid puzzle whatever puzzle it
may be okay
okay right all right all right
shut up you shut up out there you sons
of [ __ ] I'll kill you my god alright
what part ke-wah-wah some
I'm touch Nikes I didn't do anything you
back up I didn't do anything standing in
that made things go wiggly wobbly Wibbly
wibbly-wobbly Willy abrir taka though
Tran got all but there's all the
bathrooms
I mean it's logical that there would be
bathrooms in these places but why do I
have to go in so many bathrooms are a
horror show they're only meant to be
there for purposes of skiers hmm
and why are they in such disrepair was
it say HDS ah what three times what what
it said something about three times a
toilet what are you talking about maybe
the third toilet oh no because the other
the third toilet had something written
on it
gotta use it I gotta go to the bathroom
three times in here or something I don't
know what the oh god oh oh I guess what
huh
some about vandalism in the bathrooms
I'm not sure I'm talking for you who's
cyka is all right I'm just about out of
time so ha ha ha there's gonna be right
dam terrifying Aiko sworn he was gonna
get me that first time cuz my whole
screen went red with that so anyway
thank you all so much for watching click
the link in the description for uh get
the game yourself click the annotations
for videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye
knock door
love
Oh
now